We could just shed everything else, get to the radical truth, and get to the real source of the
problem versus dancing around the truth, and we could get to the source, get to the solution
right away. Absolutely important for your growth. Hey everyone, welcome to another episode of
Unlocking Lily. So I believe that this world would be a better place if we all just embrace who we
truly are. Evan is currently an investor in my business and is mentoring me to help me grow
my coaching and speaking practice, and it's an absolute honor to invite all of you guys to join
me on my startup journey. So I just celebrated my first year anniversary as an entrepreneur,
and I feel really proud in a lot of things I've accomplished as a coach. I have coached hundreds
of people from around the world, I launched the School of Life, and I have an amazing group of
ongoing clients who I get to work on on a consistent basis. And at the same time,
I am frustrated because I've hit a plateau as a coach. And the goal is always to be the best that
I can be. And right now, I'm really frustrated because I know I could be so much better. And I
know why. I know why I'm not better. It's because I have been so wrapped up and distracted by new
projects and workshops I've been working on that I forgot the fundamentals. So in this video,
I'm going to share with you the four things that I did in the beginning of my journey so that way
I could grow even faster right now. So this is all about going back to the basics and having
a beginner's mindset. Number one is practice, practice, practice. The quantity will lead to
the quality. It's amazing to have the knowledge and the theory behind you. But it's even better
if you can apply the knowledge and the theory into practice. So the more repetition that you put in,
the better you're going to get and the faster your progress is going to be.
So when I first started out, I lined up my entire calendar with coaching sessions after coaching
sessions after coaching sessions. So I set out to do 100 free coaching sessions. And we did that by
doing these three things. So the first thing that we did was we emailed a list of people who
pre-ordered Evan's book, Your One Word. As a thank you for their dedication to our mission
and cause, we gave them a free coaching session. The second thing that we did was we traded in a
comment for a free coaching session with me. So when my TEDx talk came out, I wanted to drum up
as much attention as possible. And one of those things that we did was we emailed people on Evan's
list and we asked them if they were interested in a free coaching session with me, all they had to
do was write a comment in my TEDx video. And the third thing that we did was we had daily
giveaway on this channel. So the most belief worthy comment, what does that mean? The person
that exudes the most belief and positivity will get rewarded with a free coaching session with me.
So having those three things all together, I was able to get 100 free coaching sessions.
And honestly, a lot of those free coaching sessions turned into paid ongoing clients.
And that's how I was able to get through hundreds of coaching sessions within a year.
And as a result, I got really good as a coach in a very short amount of time.
So once again, going back to the basics, I'm going to apply a lot of similar things that I did.
So right now I'm at 12 coaching sessions per week, and I'm looking to up the quantity to 18 per week,
which means I'm going to do the two things. The first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to work
with my assistant to email the waitlisted people and bring them forward to immediate spots right
now. And the second thing that we're doing is we're giving away free coaching sessions with me
via Evan's Instagram account. Again, it's going to be the most belief worthy comment. So the person
who has the most belief and oozes positivity and being supportive and contributing to the community
will win a free coaching session with me. So if you are interested in winning a free coaching
session with me, head over to Evan's Instagram account. And in any of his posts, just write
the best comment that you could possibly write. And who knows, maybe you will win a free coaching
session with me. So having those two things in place, I firmly believe that I will be able to
get the practice again, and the repetition again to get really, really good and get even better
than I am right now. Number two is self assessment. You're not always going to have someone giving you
feedback, especially when you're an entrepreneur, because a lot of the times you're working alone.
So it's important for you to self assess and get really honest with yourself and give yourself
feedback in areas that you need improvement. So after every single coaching session, what I do is
I have a little notebook beside me and I write down everything that I can improve on. And from
there, I'll do additional research and brainstorm different ideas to make it better. So one of the
things that I was working on that I was frustrated about was a beginning exercise of my coaching
sessions. So I do an exercise to set the intention for every single session. And that intention is to
be radically honest, both coming from me and from the client. And the reason why it's important
is because I want to get people results quickly, because they only have 45 minutes with me and I
want to make sure I get them as far as I can. And I cannot do that if people are dancing around the
truth. I need to get to the truth right away. And honestly, it's not because people don't want to
be honest with me. And it's not because people are lying to me. A lot of that comes from them
being afraid of judgment of me. You know, they're afraid that if they say something to me, I might
judge them for it. So I have done a bunch of different exercises before. I have done a dancing
exercise. I have done a singing exercise. And most recently, I've been doing a meditation exercise,
which has been good. It relaxes the people. It kind of brings them in focus and they're present.
But I'm still not seeing the truth right away. It still takes me about half an hour to get to the
truth. And honestly, we don't have half an hour to get to the truth. We need to get solutions right
away. So I decided to swap out the meditation exercise for something that was radically
different and high risk, but also high reward. So that exercise is going to be a confession exercise.
So at the beginning of each session, we are going to share, myself included, we are going to share
that one thing that we've been keeping really close to our heart and we have a problem sharing
because of the judgment of others. And this is where it becomes high risk because I have to be the
one to go first. And I need to share something that I feel really vulnerable towards and I'm
afraid of judgment of others. And it's high risk because it could potentially change the way the
person sees me. But it's also high reward because if we're able to see each other
eye to eye and be really honest with each other and the participant is also being honest with me,
then we could just shed everything else, get to the radical truth and get to the real source of
the problem versus dancing around the truth. And we could get to the source, get to the solution
right away and I can move them a lot faster than I've been able to do so.
So I started that experiment last week and it went pretty well. I have to say it went pretty well,
but I still have a lot more testing to do. And again, it's super risky for my part because it
takes so much vulnerability for me to sit in a place and share that side of me. But if I want
other people to share, then I got to start myself. And that's the thing. It might be very risky,
but the thing is that you don't grow if you play it safe. So it's really important for you to be
able to self assess yourself to see the areas in which you're playing small and take bigger
risks because that's how we have massive growth in our business and life. Number three, get feedback.
It's always great to get another perspective on your work, especially if it's from someone
who you respect, who has more experience than you and who you trust to be honest with you.
It's great to be validated that you're doing an amazing job, but if you want to grow,
you need someone who's going to be 100% honest and give you constructive criticism.
And that person for me is Evan. So every single Monday we will sit down for 15 minutes where we'll
break down one of my coaching calls. And that's where he is very honest with me and gives me
feedback on everything that I need to improve on. And I love it because I know if I applied
those feedback, I could get better really, really quickly. And the reason why it's important to get
feedback like that is for two reasons. The first thing is that no matter how much self-awareness
you have, you're still going to have some blind spots and it's impossible for you to work on
things that you just simply cannot see. So having that person seeing the things that you can't see,
you could find ways to actually get better in those areas. And the second part is you're not
always going to have the answers and that's okay. So having someone who again has been through the
process before, who has more experience than you, could help you get some of those answers that
you're looking for and help you get unstuck. So having someone that will give you feedback,
sometimes it takes a lot of humility to take feedback, especially if you're sensitive about
your work, but it's absolutely important for your growth. Number four, model the masters.
If there's an area that you want to get really great at, there is a master in it that you could
study really closely that you could model after to fast track your way to success.
Now this is something I used to do a lot in the beginning of my journey when I was starting off
with nothing. So I would just study for hours and hours and hours of videos of people who I looked
up to, speakers and coaches, and I would try to model after them. And it worked really well for
me in the beginning, but somewhere down the line I stopped doing it. Probably in the last six months
I haven't modeled the masters at all because I just got so wrapped up in all the new things that's
been happening. I've had school of life launch. I've also been doing a lot of YouTube lives and
I've my coaches corner, everything else that I just haven't done it at all. It just kind of
fell down my priority. And also recently I realized that modeling the masters was one of the key
factors in helping me grow as a speaker and as a coach. That's how I was able to grow that fast.
So I knew I had to make it a priority all over again. Now I work seven days a week. So which
means that me making time for modeling the masters, I have to cut out something else in my calendar.
So I decided to clear up one of the things I was working on that wasn't really much of a priority
and not showing me as much results as I would like. And I replaced that with just investing
time in watching videos and consuming books of coaches that I look up to and seeing how
they do interventions. So that way I could apply it to my coaching sessions as well.
Now I have seen these videos many times over in the past but this time I'm going to take a
different approach. And that's the thing. You could have read a book many times over and over again
or if you could have seen a video over and over again. Doesn't mean that you can't go back and
watch it from a fresh set of eyes. Because now I'm going back from a person who is more experienced.
Because before I had nothing to begin with. And now I have had a lot of experience behind me.
I've had hundreds of coaching sessions behind me and I have lived through this business. So I'm
looking at it from a very analytical perspective as opposed to the consumer perspective that I did
before. So now for example I am going to look at Tony Robbins's intervention instead of sitting
back and consuming it and see how wonderful he is. Which he still is. But looking at it from how can I
reverse engineering what he's doing to apply that to my coaching practice as well.
And again modeling the masters is something that has to keep happening in your life. You know it
doesn't happen like what I did in the first six months and it just ends. It has to keep going on.
And again having the humility inside of you knowing that you don't know everything and you
still have a lot more to go is going to really help you in your growth as well. And I have a
special shout out for Skylar and friends. Thank you so much for writing not one but two comments in my
last video. And I want to let you know that your support means a lot to me. So guys I'm really
excited to go back to the basics and apply these four things into my progress so that way I could
be the best coach that I can be. So the question of the day is which one of these four things are
you going to apply in helping yourself grow even faster? Write in the comments below and I'll join
in on the discussion. Thank you guys so much for watching and more importantly being on this
journey with me. I feel like I'm growing learning and changing and it gives me the comfort in knowing
that you guys are with me every step of the way. So thank you so much again and I'll see you guys
very very soon. Bye. So let me give you the one word secret to happiness. One word. This is all you
need to be happy. The most important word ever. If you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or that would be kind of like a little beacon.
Hey Believe Nation! If you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins,
Gary Vaynerchuk, Oprah Winfrey, will.i.am, and Howard Schultz, I have a very special
secret video for you. Check the description for details.